afghanistan's winter chill has brought
fresh levels of suffering to a people
who've endured decades of it
and in one of the poorest countries its
poorest region may well be the
birthplace of the world's largest
humanitarian disaster
so the women of bantis queue for hours
just for free paracetamol for the sick
in afghanistan's most deprived province
nothing comes easy and everything's
scarce
desperation is the only commodity not in
short supply here
they're having to cram babies onto beds
in the main provincial hospital it's
standing room only here
a measles outbreak is ripping through
them in the tiny with already poor
immunity measles can be a death sentence
the insecurities meant vaccines haven't
been given
and there are widespread claims it's the
taliban who prevented them
the number of measles here is very high
the doctor tells us we don't know how to
help them he says it's very hard for all
of us
the talib now in charge of health
services has no medical qualifications
and left school at 14. not so long ago
he was fighting foreign troops and
blames others for the current mess
everyone knows the previous president
ashraf ghani was the most corrupt person
in the most corrupt government in the
world he tells us and we have a lack of
everything
that means those who are least able are
losing this fight
erezzo breathed her last aching with
hunger and in a bitingly cold tent
her father traveled three hours to this
their nearest hospital
but no one can help his daughter now
the two-year-old's parents wrap up her
frozen body with the air of people with
no hope who never expected help and
didn't get it
we're living in tents her father says
some people don't even have tents where
we are there's no warm place and that's
why she died
there's no time for grief they've two
more children to keep alive
[Music]
there are too many like
perished starving and cold
it never gets any easier
misery stalks every corridor and every
ward
[Music]
cadia has a range of complications all
of them normally treated easily but
these are not normal times in a country
where little is functioning normally
right now
the baby has pneumonia measles a fever
and at the root of it all poverty and
little food
they bring in a nebulizer to help
it seems to do little
in a country where billions were spent
over two decades the young are suffering
terribly
later the same night after filming this
caddie also succumbed afghanistan's
babies are dying at a shockingly high
rate
in the maternity wards samaya and the
other teenage mothers edged towards
labour filled with fear
like asia she was sold into marriage at
14.
they're all living in a country with one
of the highest maternal mortality rates
every girl here knows surviving the
birthing experience will be one of their
toughest challenges
i'm really scared i'm going to die asia
says
[Music]
when 16 year old samaya is finally
trying to deliver her baby there's no
pain relief there are few medicines at
all here the midwives must cut her if
her baby's going to be delivered alive
it's been a difficult and traumatic
delivery
and the baby is completely limp and
unresponsive
[Music]
bring a towel
i'm really scared the exhausted new
mother says
she's worried for herself and her
newborn son
she looks on as the midwives work fast
now
every second is going to count if this
baby is going to live
he doesn't appear to be breathing
they frantically suck out the amniotic
fluid which is threatening to drown him
they have few medical tools to help them
save this baby
but my goodness they're using them as
best they can
[Music]
then finally
but he's not yet out of danger and still
not responding well he's taken to the
resuscitation room where there's a
rolling queue of babies needing help
they need to get more oxygen inside this
baby's lungs
but the hand pump is defective
most of these medics are working for
very little and have hardly been paid
since the taliban came to power and
foreign aid suddenly stopped
[Music]
but this little boy's battle to live is
their fight too both mother and baby
have somehow got through this but the
baby starts his life in a land where
most are hungry and the entire afghan
society is teetering on the edge of
collapse
alex crawford sky news